[Musique]
les films historiques suscite toujours
beaucoup d'intérêt ils nous permettent
de revisiter le passé avec le regard du
présent qui est à amputer un peu la
réalité dans ces faits
jason cinéma d'embellie commencions par
jeff qui donneront naissance en est un
qui avait tous les ingrédients problème
absolument argent pouvoir trahison le
film commence vraiment comme un
documentaire les versions de vraiment
voulu brouiller la piste entre la
fiction et le documentaire donc on y va
avec des images d'archivés me rappelle
le contexte historique
mais dès le début si on lit
attentivement générique c'est écrit que
le film est basé sur un ruck sur deux
romans on va dire donc celui de jim
garrison quitte le procureur américain
interprété dans le film par kevin sa
soeur qui était déterminé à prouver que
dire qu'ils n'avaient pas été tués par
lee harvey oswald seul mais bien par un
complot ourdi entre autres par lasser de
l'apparition du terme à leur histoire
était accusée de renforcer ce sentiment
complotistes malgré tout le film a
remporté un vif succès remporté des
oscars aussi et ont soulevé des
questions dans l'opinion publique tant
et si bien que le film contribué à faire
déclassifiés certains documents wacom
maastricht on y brise se termine avec un
plaidoyer de kevin turner qui regardent
le jury et qui leur dit il a produit son
effet ça produit son effet tenté si bien
que le congrès a déjà adopté une loi qui
déclassifier des documents qui faisaient
en sorte qu'ils allaient tous être
réunis au même endroit pour que les gens
puissent plus facilement consulter et se
faire une idée mais malgré tout et c'est
le propre des théories du complot ça ne
gèlent réussi à discipline complètement
les doutes du public américain sur les
véritables causes de la mort de conclure
maintenant dhabi avec un film que j'ai
sur le plan cinématographique le
grandement apprécié et c'est dans l'air
du temps pas beaucoup de l'iran en ce
moment le film argo qui focalise sur
cette prise d'otages dans l'ambassade
américaine il ya 40 ans
si les faire quitter le pays ont leurs
garnisons un faux film et en faisant
semblant que ces diplomates le sont en
fait des membres d'une équipe de
tournage sur la base des faits c'est une
vraie histoire cette histoire s'est
réellement passé
mais là encore on prend beaucoup de
liberté au niveau de la réalité
historique
on avait complètement minimiser le rôle
de l'ambassadeur canadien et du canada
cette évasion est pourtant même le
président américain jimmy carter dit oui
le film est bon mais je crois qu'on a
quand même sous-estimé puisque c'était
90 % la part canadien qui avait permis
de libérer selon un diplomate il pas
temps que c'est de travailler 10 % de
travail de la cia et des amériques est
d'ailleurs à l'époque que nos collègues
de tout le monde en parle et avait
réalisé une émission d'une heure où on
peut revoir je demande la vérité versus
et la fiction qui toujours d'ailleurs
disponible sur le site de radio canada
je pense que la morale de tout ça ça
peut être de prendre le tout avec un
petit grain de sel c'est les films de
fiction et ce grain d'sel on peut le
mettre dans le pop corn et profiter d'un
bon divertissement avec des barres et de
président et de faire nos propres
recherches aussi sur l'histoire telle
qu'elle s'est déroulée
absolument c'est le meilleur moyen
d'avoir la vérité